boy it's really terrific to be here
thank you for the invitation and to be
back on the Stanford campus our company
has just located one exit north on 280
off in redwood city and it's a special
opportunity to be here and participate
in your activities and kick off this to
this season I also thought it was really
interesting to be here on the fifth
anniversary of the passing of Steve Jobs
is today and the importance that Steve
has had as an icon in Silicon Valley and
this is one of my favorite photos of
Steve and it's going to reinforce a
little bit some of the topic I want to
talk about here in the beginning related
to ideas innovation and entrepreneurship
and where what is a intersection or
feeding ground for those ideas and as
you can imagine from this perspective
here you know firmly believe that it's a
lot of different disciplines coming
together that can make a big impact and
and steve is noted for saying it's in
Apple's DNA that technology alone is not
enough its technology married with the
liberal arts married with the humanities
that yields us a result that makes our
heart sing and I think that's really a
essence of a lot of advances today of
that intersection and if you look around
and you look at there are so many
opportunities actually so many needs for
big breakthroughs and big ideas whether
you're thinking about new ways of
storing energy new ways of curing
diseases new ways of protecting
information and cyber security or
national security and any opportunities
for making an impact and in particular
being here at a university I know and I
love quotes you'll see different quotes
coming up but this quote here from Henry
rosovsky was the Dean at Harvard one of
my favorite researches an expression of
faith and a possibility of progress the
drive that leads scholars to study a
topic has to include the belief that new
things can be discovered that newer can
be
and that a greater depth of
understanding is achievable research
especially academic research is a form
of optimism about the human condition
and i love the actual poetic pneus of
that statement and that in that
perspective and it's what really drives
me and and historically my students over
the years and what Steve what has done
so well and you think about what Apple
has done you think about the
intersection of a great hardware and
great software but really thinking about
how it changes society how we interact
with one another how we think and what
that really is is the convergence of
disciplines and I had the privilege of
chairing a National Academy study on
convergence in its impact and driving
innovation and you know historically the
word convergence and its meaning has
often implied the convergence of the
physical sciences engineering and
medicine in fact that's the way MIT has
classically referred to convergence but
I think you know what it really means
it's bringing together disciplines in
maybe not so obvious ways and thinking
about what emerges from that but I think
more broadly and what Apple has done is
I think you have to think about
extending this to the social sciences
the humanities and perhaps even the
Performing Arts in thinking about tech
in the humanities and the liberal arts
is an important aspect and as part of
that I think a lot of people believe
that convergence itself is actually a
blueprint for innovation if one can get
convergence right it can be real a
driver for new ideas and you know coming
back to Apple and you think about you
know who Apple has gathered around the
innovation desk if you will it's not
just the techies it's not just the
hardware and software folks but you know
looking at some of the recent hires you
know former CEO of e st. Laurent former
CEO burberry designer from Nike all
these different people coming together
in a rather not so obvious way to think
about changing the way we live and
that's a really important pattern do you
think about what does that mean here in
universities
universities are interesting we often
deal with an 18th century organized
organizational structure right where
there's where their silos in fact I find
it ironic at universities are one of the
few places where entropy doesn't work
mixing is not natural here and you
really have to fight through those
barriers and encourage a lot of the new
people here at Stanford is so many
resources here on campus to be able to
break through and reach two different
connections and that's really what this
is talking about and you'll see part of
this aspect is and when you think about
the kinds of people at carbon or at
Apple you know you'll see this metaphor
of eye shape people or t-shape people
you know people that I shape being very
monolithic in a particular discipline in
the metaphor of a t-shaped person deep
in a subject but be able to go and
interact with others you know I think
what nowadays there's a higher calling
and it's a pie shaped or comb-shaped
people right where you actually are deep
in multiple subjects and conversant in
most of multiple subjects and this
really takes it beyond what may be a
common language associated with t-shaped
people but the ability to be
multilingual and go deep in multiple
subjects which is really important to
make a difference today and part of that
when you gather people around and one of
the core cultural values of up for us a
carbon is that when you are working with
a diverse set of people that there's
going to be a there's going to be a need
to be clear about not only what you know
but what you don't know and there's a
vulnerable trust that one has to have if
you're going to be clear to your
colleagues about what you don't know and
that's in an essence that's a critical
characteristic value that we have at
carbon let me expand this a little bit
further when I started my academic
career in the early 1990s I got a chance
to be invited to an innovation committee
or workshop at a very large chemical
firm and i flew outside the united
states to get there and i walked into
this innovation group and it was a
pretty sterile looking bored
room like this but what was a maid
really amazing to me was not always it
was a tall white guys around the table
but they all graduated from the same to
research groups right and you know what
I mean when I say that I mean everybody
knew each other everybody knew what each
other new and I felt like a Martian
coming into this environment and I never
felt more like an outsider than when I
did walked into that room and it dawned
on me right then and there that this
group was at a structural disadvantage
the way they were organized to drive
innovation and you know a lot of people
have talked about this where the
recognition that diversity is a
fundamental tenet of innovation I talked
a little bit about disciplinary
diversity in the beginning but diversity
more broadly defined and in recognizing
that diversity plays a really important
role it doesn't always trump ability but
it does so far more often than we expect
and it's really great book by Scott page
called the difference what I find
intriguing in a lot of different sectors
of our society and our organizations
that once you start talking about
diversity in the role that it has on
driving innovation the very quickly
people will come up and start talking
about ability the meritocracy and
there's often a very quick a pivot that
says you know that the meritocracy is
really the driver and shall we be should
we giving up the meritocracy clearly no
ability matters no question about it but
the point is so does diversity there are
different topics there are absolutely
different topics nothing is more
impactful than a diverse set of
individuals driving towards a common
goal to make a difference and it's this
exponential different diversity that's
really important you know you know
recognizing early on that we learn the
most from those that we have the least
in common with right and you think about
that if your part if you're getting part
of a design team and you're fortunate to
be part of a design team you recognize
that these different experiences drive
the innovation process i can tell you
more times than not at different design
teams I've been associated with what's
if somebody grew up with not much money
they think about problem solving
fundamentally different then somebody
that grew up with a lot of money not
that one is better than the other
they're just different and if your goal
is to broaden the perspectives around
the table then you have to think about
this diversity this element of diversity
to drive innovation and you know
recognizing that some of the most
innovative solutions comes from
embracing that diversity of perspective
and and so I think it you know my sort
of message here is that I think we need
to be intentional about this diversity
or you're going to lose out it's really
the secret sauce of a lot of different
companies especially those companies
that are trying to drive something very
profoundly different and diversity is a
recognized fundamental tenet of
innovation again I love books I love
quotes Peter Thiel is a has a really
terrific book 0 to 1 and it's got some
really interesting perspectives and a
take home for me was about thinking
about ideas and this in its fundamental
tenets to he has is you know what
important truth too few people agree
with you on and it embedded in that is
what he thinks is a zero to one idea a
profoundly different idea and that ideas
come in two flavors seminal 01 ideas and
then incremental ideas 1 to n ideas and
you think about that you think about
what it is you're working on and you
think about especially in an academic
setting and think about where those
breakthrough ideas are and its really
convincing people about building a
different future and that's really an
element of a characteristic but those of
you that think about academia if you
have an idea that very few people agree
with you on and you try to go get
funding right through traditional
mechanisms peer review what does that
necessarily mean it's not going to get
funded which is ironic when you think
about NSF and NIH and traditional
funding mechanisms about the need for
these breakthrough ideas and having
people agree with you
so one has to be entrepreneurial and
think about getting some of these ideas
done respect even at a university
because the access to funds may be there
professorships maybe there are other
kinds of fellowships it gives you the
latitude to pursue crazy ideas but in
those ideas are those 0 to 1
breakthrough ideas and so thinking about
the differences between academia and a
private sector I think venture capital
is the fuel for some of the craziest
ideas and that's what I love about doing
what I'm doing now bridging academia and
and entrepreneurship another element
that you'll think about with ideas
anybody know who had this quote you do
not merely want to be considered just
the best of the best you want to be
considered the only ones that do what
you do anybody know some of the older
folks Jerry Garcia right and so again
back to strategies all about being
different another term that you'll hear
from the business folks working on
different ideas doing something
different you know there's a lot of
software people now writing a lot of
code to push advertisements on people
right there's a lot of focus on that and
if you can now do something different
than that or finding a hotel room or or
other things there's a lot of
opportunities for driving software to do
things that are different encourage you
to think about those things right that's
a bit of a challenge and then for me too
especially in an academic environment
back to this 18th century quote from
Goethe which is almost like the Nike
commercial just do it the translational
aspects of research coming back to where
we started taking ideas taking the
essence of great research targeted at
addressing societal problems can be a
really powerful mantra and for us and
over my career this has meant
participating in a number of new
companies that did some game-changing
things that we believe in some are more
game-changing in others this was a
biodegradable stent that goes away after
18 months that company was acquired by
Gaiden now part of Abbott we have about
150,000 people there degradable stents
in them this is a nano biotech company
called loquilla make
particles engineer particles using the
tools of the micro electronics industry
to make medicines and so bridging
bridging photolithography and and and
medicines for new drug delivery
approaches again opportunities for
bridging very dramatic ideas this is a
battery company located in Berkeley that
has non flammable electrolytes or
lithium ion batteries who would be
interested in that today there's there's
a few of us maybe with laptops owner on
our laps let alone on airplanes and and
then let me tell you about a company
that I'm very excited about and that I'm
here representing with few of my
colleagues here and its carbon so I'm
going to talk to you refer to give you a
bit of a glimpse into what we think is a
breakthrough an additive manufacturing
or 3d printing and we use pattern light
and I'm going to refer to light as our
chisel I love that metaphor of light as
a chisel and this work was described in
science about 18 months ago happened to
be on the cover of science and the
embargo on the science paper was lifted
the moment I walked in with the stages
of Ted and and then our company came out
of stealth mode so I think from an
entrepreneurial point of view I think of
that as an entrepreneurial hattrick
paper and science coming out of stealth
mode TED talk worked out pretty well for
us so that's a good recipe to get
launched so 3d printing everyone's
familiar with 3d printing everyone's
familiar 3d printing President Obama's
talking about 3d printing and I think
it's a clear to say that 3d printing has
not emerged to be a significant
industrial sector yet in fact you just
look at the dollars it's only a four or
five billion dollar industry to put that
into context the u.s. polymer industry
is a 400 billion dollar industry okay
and a four to five billion includes
metals and their primary reasons why 3d
printing has not emerged to be
manufacturing it's a terrific
prototyping technology but the prints
take forever they're not at
a speed that's economically viable the
layers give rise to anisotropic
properties and it as a real problem in
designing proper material properties for
complex devices in the material choices
that are available are pretty limited
and so when you think about other great
books to read Jeffrey more crossing the
chasm or inside the tornado those of you
and do an entrepreneurship those are
classic books Jeffrey would say that 3d
printing has fallen into the chasm in a
chasm is in this technology adoption
curve where in the beginning of all new
technology introductions the techies
drive adoption techies love products in
fact late love products that are not
complete they like to cobble together a
partial solution and that's part of what
they love to do but to really get to the
early majority or the large volume of
revenue you need an economically viable
solution people don't care about
technology on the other side of the
chasm they want a solution that's
economically viable and a technology
that falls into the chasm has some
significant shortcomings and a lot of us
believe the 3d printing has done that
and I think this is a good
representation at this is a classic 3d
printing technology called sls spreading
powder a laser sintering of pushing it
into the table and then gets pushed out
and somewhere buried in a cake of powder
is a product right this is one of the
mainstays of 3d printing today it's
called selective laser sintering sls
this is being done with a nylon or poly
centering it together this is
essentially identical to hewlett
packard's HP's new technology new
technology it's this technology may be
done in a bigger format but it's a
centering of powder right for an atomic
solid for metals this works pretty well
because there's essentially no memory
the grain boundary for an atomic solid
but for a molecular solid like a polymer
the mechanical properties of polymers
are all derived from what are called
chain entanglements think of it as
spaghetti
and in knots and ties between that
entanglements drive the mechanical
properties of polymeric materials and
you don't get the entanglements between
particles like you do at the center of a
particle or from injection molding by
this technology and so there's lots of
shortcomings so this technology for
molecular materials so given this
perspective that 3d printing is actually
2d printing over and over again we
thought we could come up with a
different way and our approach was
focused on could we do this continuously
and I'm a chemist and I think about I
think like chemists do because I'm a
chemist and I think about like growing
crystals chemists like to grow stuff
right and our approach to doing this and
this is actually a video that we did for
on the stages of Ted we did a live 3d
print during a TED talk this is an
accelerated video a one-minute video but
took about seven minutes to run the
print and a key to our approach for
doing this was a process that would
emerge kind of looks like t1000 at a
terminator to write growing out of a
broth or out of a puddle and in order
for that to work we needed a new
approach to doing 3d printing and our
approach involved a reservoir shown here
with liquid and at the bottom of the
reservoir was a very special window and
below the window was a projection system
and in this case operating in the
ultraviolet at 385 nanometers so we're
doing UV curing of chemistry but what's
also key about this window is it not
only transparent to light but it's
highly permeable to oxygen okay that was
a good it was that's the punchline all
right it's a it's highly permeable to
oxygen and the key for that is oxygen
inhibits the photochemistry oxygen
prevents the the photochemistry from
taking place and so oxygen and light
work and polar opposite ways okay so
it's a chemical approach to growing
parts as opposed to a mechanical
engineering approach
doing 2d printing over and over again
and and this is an example of our
printer that was the technology debut
about 18 months ago that video this is
actually our our first product that we
launched this past spring and this is
what we call em one it's m4 medium it's
our first product you can get a sense of
our product lines and the nomenclature
it's pretty simple but this is pattern
light emerging from underneath as we
pull out more complex objects and let me
just grab this one here this is actually
this part growing out of the broth this
is an air duct for a NASCAR and you see
it coming pulling out of the liquid so
it's really just coming out of the
puddle here and we're basically using
pattern light and doing a choreography
with a z-axis and fine tuning a lot of
chemistry's I think of this as
software-controlled chemical reactions
to rapidly grow apart okay this
particular part has a use temperature up
over 225 degrees Celsius right and so
this is a really high performance very
high modulus material it's got a 4.5
gigapascal modulus and the essence of
our process is shown here this is
something called optical coherence
tomography this is analogous to doing
ultrasound imaging but with light and
set of sound waves and this is our
window and this is we're growing a two
millimeter diameter part at 200
millimeters an hour instead of a layer
by layer approach these speckles are
nanoparticles that we added as a
contrast agent so you can see the flow
of liquid and so what's happening is
lights coming through right here at the
bottom at this diameter two millimeters
to generate the cylinder but what's
happening is oxygen is also coming
through and so the oxygen prevents the
light from solidifying the resin right
at the window okay and it creates a gap
what we call a dead zone where the
photochemistry doesn't take place a dead
zone is about thirty five microns thick
right about a third of
diameter of a human hair and so what
happens is as we pull the part up
suction forces bring the liquid in
underneath and theres a river of resin
that flows in underneath the part
maintains the puddle so as we pull the
parts up it allows us to grow these
parts and so this is our process and
when we start making parts in this
manner if you cleave the part if I have
this bicycle pedal here if you cleave
this part this example of a bicycle
pedal that we've printed and you end and
you can see it's got a lot of different
angles to it while you're printing it
okay if this were made by a traditional
3d printer there would be layers
oriented relative to the orientation of
how you printed the part and in
traditional 3d printed parts that
layering gives rise to an isotropic
properties properties thrive from the
orientation of the layers but when we
grow parts in this manner especially
with the kinds of chemistry we use and
you cleave the part there's no remnants
of us changing each image slice right
it's uniform by all means of analysis
right so these parts are isotropic right
they don't have the orientation
dependence of mechanical properties and
that becomes really really important for
making final parts and so as we think
about our business and how we want to
bring this forward and you think about
the age that we live in today we live in
a subscription age right the age of
where soft used to buy software in a box
those of us with with disks remember
disks floppy disks right some of those
were 12 inches way before a lot of you
guys were born all right and then it got
smaller and harder and you don't buy
software that way anymore right it's a
subscription well we're we offer our
machine in a similar pattern mode
instead of software as a service this is
hardware as a service okay it's a
subscription model you can think of it
as a rental right and what this does it
gives a couple things first of all its
internet connected we get the push saw
where every five or six weeks to the to
the printer our vp of engineering craig
carlson was the vp of engineering at
tesla right my car just got a software
upgrade the other night with new
features on it new parking new autopilot
features in fact the UI change I don't
even know where the music is anymore
right now I hope we don't do that when
we push software but but the ability of
pushing software to the device allows us
to add new features to the printer and
one of the most important new features
allows us to design new resins and
develop the technology to make new
resins printable and control that dead
zone in particular and so the details
for example one of the most important
reasons of having an internet-connected
printer is there's a whole lot of
properties that impact that dead zone
okay think about how much lights
required to solidify a different resin
you change the chemistry you change the
details of that photochemistry what is
the viscosity of the resin how far does
a light penetrate into that liquid right
what are the mechanical properties of
the part while it's being built what's
the machine configuration what's apart
geometry and so we've mapped all this
all these fundamentals out and I'll just
show you one example this is us building
an Eiffel Tower this is a temperature
profile that happens while we build
something like an Eiffel Tower right you
can see the temperatures changing right
for chemical reactions every 10 degree
change in temperature reaction rates
double on average viscosity is changing
this really impacts the details of
controlling that dead zone here's one of
our prototype printers now operating
another factor of 10 this is going at
two thousand millimeters an hour right
and if you look carefully you'll see it
growing and then you'll see some smoke
coming off the parts now as a chemical
engineer I'm showing off here a little
bit right we have to run our 3d printers
where we have to start thinking about
water cooling them right and and heat
transfer becomes a limit on a mass
transfer and heat transfer become really
key limits on us how fast we can go
right but this is now two orders of
magnitude 5
then what we showed on the stages of Ted
and so my point in saying all that is
that our customers don't have to worry
about that we have a print button right
we have a team of yeah it's it's a
simple statement right we have the most
amazing team of chemists biologists
geneticists physicist figuring out the
fundamental cores of how to control the
dead zone and make a great part and that
drives an algorithm that drives the
printer right so it's a simple print
button and that's what this that's what
people want nowadays all they have to do
is pick their geometry pick their resin
and we take care of the rest and that's
how we do this okay and you need
software be able to update software over
time and having an internet-connected
device to do that and so we have over 25
sensors built into the printer they
stream over a million data points a day
each one back to our servers at amazon
web services we're collecting a massive
amount of data on how to print well all
the operational data associated with the
printer and this data rich environment
is really what you hear about in a
digital factory of the future today
right our customers want this kind of
operational data right every time apart
is made called the born on data right we
have a log of data associated with when
this part was made right so we have all
those operational details and that can
all be fed back into your ERP system
associated with the manufacturer of
these parts think about the
opportunities for new business models
that that transforms if they if a part
brakes on a car right and you don't have
a connection or you don't have traceable
parts right you have to recall maybe six
hundred thousand vehicles imagine the
opportunity for just recalling the
twelve hundred vehicles associated with
may be that bad lot or resin if you
could have an identity on the part tied
back to all the operational data or
maybe a medical device in post-market
surveillance where you can now have that
kind of data associated with your
products
or maybe you have authentic parts
whether your BMW or Mercedes and you're
thinking about your brand and your
design and maybe your intellectual
property and be able to be able to have
that kind of tie back to your particular
products one of the things that's
essential for us to is that those of you
that are familiar with 3d printing it's
not uncommon that the first time you try
to print something there are defects
right and for us this would be an
example of a defect this delamination
this is where maybe the dead zone got
away from us too much oxygen not enough
light pulling too fast and it
delaminated our customers get to score
the quality of the parts we get to
change the printing algorithm so that
that class a problem doesn't happen
again and then we get to push new
software and fix the problem this is a
network effect and if you read another
great book by Eric Schmidt on how Google
works or bill curlee and being part of
the 10 X Club one of the essential
characteristics of an interest really
interesting business model today is
having a network effect that is the more
people use this printer that better it's
getting right so the bigger we get the
better we get and that's a really
interesting powerful drive for us going
forward in the future but at the end of
the day for us it's all about having
great parts real parts and those of you
are familiar with 3d printing you often
don't have the materials needed to be a
viable part if you design a bicycle
pedal for maybe a new mountain bike and
you design it on your favorite CAD
software and your printed on a
traditional 3d printer you can actually
have the device you can look at and say
yeah it looks like what I designed it
it's the right intent but you often
can't put it on the bicycle and go for a
bike ride because it will fail and we
have been focused on amazing materials
that have final properties and so
traditionally and if you look at
mechanical properties this is a stress
strain curve this is a brittle material
made by traditional a lot of life based
traditional 3d printers but what you
want in the real world are materials
that have ductile like properties
advanced
so you figure out all the materials
polymeric materials on cars or on the
clothing you're wearing or the wearable
electronic devices that you have there's
a range of properties that are necessary
to drive the hardware solutions that
people are interested in today and so we
have to be able to generate those and
our unique approach to doing this was to
use light to set the shape but we use
chemistry to set the properties and this
is all enabled by having software so for
example we can make apart like this and
and set the shape and then we go through
a baking process which triggers other
chemistry's that does chain extension
allows us to go to high molecular weight
and have really great material
properties and so we've got a whole
family of materials and we are setting
up an app store for resins okay an app
store for resins so you think about why
one sets up app stores to begin with
it's to engage a community engage a
developer community to trigger ideas and
innovations from others to work on your
platform but it also does something else
for us it sets up a marketplace for
think about driving down pricing right
if you actually want to go into
manufacturing and that's where we're
going you need some truth in pricing
right traditional 2d printing companies
you think about your favorite you know
copier toner is very expensive you're
never going to get to large volume
manufacturing with toner like pricing so
you need to set up a marketplace dynamic
and that's what we've been able to do so
we have real materials that allow us to
generate real parts and I'll just walk
you through some examples of these that
first one I mentioned this is assigned a
tester most people don't know what sign
a testers are which is okay but you walk
into companies like SpaceX Boeing NASA
they know what sign a testers are these
are advanced composite materials these
are materials have used temperatures up
over 200 degrees Celsius very chemically
resistant compatible with sterilization
a lot of our surgical tool companies are
interested in materials that are
sterilized abul for applications in
medicine
we have these rigid polyurethanes these
are some parts on the Mini Cooper we've
got parts driving around on these cars
for the last almost a year now going
through a Bavarian winter and now
Bavarian summer and now going back into
a Bavarian winter I should get back over
there for Oktoberfest actually these are
some additional parts and our customers
and us are putting these parts through
validation studies right meeting the
application needs either an ISO standard
or UL rating or anything specific to
those companies examples where we pass
UV testing door handles that look like
injection molded polycarbonate ABS
blends as an example these are some
really interesting parts this was a
metal bracket machined out of aluminum
for our printer and once we started
having printers we were using our
printers to make parts for themselves
right sort of a singularity moment
crossing that line and and so this is an
example of a part printed out of a rigid
polyurethane that meets all the
specifications necessary for this
bracket for this motor okay and what's
really interesting is you think about
additive this is clearly designed by a
human it looks like something you Minh
would design but what's really
interesting and jade up here is a
student here at Stanford did an
internship with us she fed this design
into some of the new generative design
software and had them had the software
optimize it for stiffness so keep the
mask constant and what design would give
the stiffest part and the computer spits
out something that looks more like the
Klingon warship then maybe the Starship
Enterprise and very organic-looking but
this is where designs going today in
generative design right there's another
design where instead of keeping the mass
constant and maximize stiffness keep
this difference of this and minimize the
mass right in applications of light
waiting vehicles right or minimizing
costs by eliminating material lowering
your carbon footprint right making a
material light an example so that's
those are the kinds of things that when
light is your chisel the
kinds of complex structures are easy to
access we have amazing materials for
epoxy you know electrical connectors
there's over 800 electrical connectors
on a tesla car right this is a 37
billion dollar market electrical
connectors and if you walk into these
factories and it was just at delphi
large company injection molding company
a room that was five times the size of
this room with 200 ton injection molding
machines cranking out electrical
connectors they take plastic pellets
they heat it up to the melting point of
the polymer they use 200 tons of
injection force to push a very viscous
polymer melt into a very finite cavity
it costs about half a million dollars
but most importantly it's a design of
the cavity or design of the part such
you can open up the cavity in and pull
the part out it has a symmetry that
allows you to open up a cavity but
they're so mental is designed for
manufacturability not for use right and
I'm really I'm really interested in how
can we train a hundred thousand
engineers to design for use and not
focus on manufacturability and use it
opens up the design space if you just
focus on what it is you want because
with additive manufacturing complexity
is free you don't have to worry about
design rules that's the advantage of
these kinds of new and new approaches
elastomers we have superpowers in
elastomers and as again i'm a materials
guy like you know we have superpowers
these elastomers have very high tear
strength very high resiliency and we can
make amazing things from rubber gaskets
two hearing aids to athletic footwear
and we have some amazing things coming
in a very near future making amazing
kinds of footwear products and it's
going to be Footwear it's not just
designed for size eight nine ten or
twelve but it would be bespoke and it'd
be designed for you and again that's
another fundamental tenet of a digital
manufacturing footprint
and so again just our materials allow us
to go through hundreds of thousands of
cycle tests have all the properties to
to be real materials and so again with a
data-centric environment we can see all
the different industry server tickles
automotive consumer products education
industrial medical service bureaus a
contract manufacturers which resins are
using I get this data every night
midnight my wife's about to shoot me
because I wait for this report every
night get to see all the data that
happens and we have an amazing set of
customers now again we launched our
product in March we have lots of
different fortune 500 companies major
industrials we have service bureaus or
contract manufacturers that are
supporting many other companies they're
in the business that make parts and then
we have a lot of different academic
institutions and you can imagine it's
really challenging for both the
University of North Carolina and Duke to
be in the same row here and again as I
mentioned to you that we're coming out
with this printer as a subscription
model right it's a rental what this
really does is it aligns us with our
customers printing right this is not a
transactional sale it's a partnership
and most importantly this future proofs
our customers right I know the product
roadmap I know when this product's going
to be obsolete our customers don't have
to worry about that right they're not
locked in their future proofed and
especially for a company like us it's
just coming out with a brand new
technology you know I don't have the
heart to have people buy stuff that I
know is going to be obsolete and so the
subscription model for lots of reasons
becomes an important way to move a new
product into the marketplace and then we
sell resins we're setting up that with
the App Store and we have some other
accessories but our total reason for
being as a company is to create a new
industrial category of 3d manufacturing
a lot of people are talking about 3d
manufacturing but as you saw in the very
beginning the technology's fallen into
the chasm it's today still about
prototyping and our thesis is that we
can we're trying a lot of companies will
do
I would call the long jump try to cross
the chasm we have the privilege or
opportunity to do a triple jump right
all we need to do is we're putting our
printer into the existing prototype
market allowing the prototype is to
actually make real parts we call that
functional prototyping right while we're
doing that we've got some signature
customers some signature accounts that
we're trying to develop whole solutions
for manufacturing right and we're going
to take the next two or three years in
parallel to putting this 3d printer into
the prototyping market we're also
developing full manufacturing solutions
where we're making hundreds of thousands
and millions of parts a year in some new
industry verticals such that these two
worlds will come together so we're
building out really a factory of the
future where there's clusters of our
machines the machines are designed for
automated fluid delivery where their
software written to control a fleet of
printers where we have encryption data
so that people can have the security
that they want whether they're an
aerospace company or whether they're in
Hollywood and their designs are just as
important as aerospace companies so all
that software all that infrastructure to
build a digital factory is really really
important and part of that and part of
our thesis to is one of the most
important places to have unique mass
customized products is in medicine right
auct about it for Footwear but you think
about teeth you think about ears noses
sleep you know CPAP mask for sleep apnea
all sorts of places coronary devices I
told you in the beginning I started a
biodegradable stent company right you
think about that that's it's not
different than buying shoes right what's
you know the interventional cardiac at
table and it's an emergency situation
and you've got a blockage in the
interventional cardiologist she looks up
on the cath on the on the TV screen and
looks at your blockage she's this makes
a decision what size stent that you need
in that particular blood vessel you
don't want a standard stent right you
want a stent design for your Anatomy
right and what's the fact you know the
future is going to be a situation where
she can look
at that maybe do some drawings right on
the screen the software calculates what
stent you need for your particular
blockage or your particular tributaries
off that off that vessel hit a print
button it prints a stent and then she
can place it into you designed for you
right on a cath table right that's the
future I don't want to push that through
the FDA today but those kinds of things
are happening and in medicine it's going
to be a really powerful opportunity so
we believe that this breakthrough
approach real materials made a game
changing speeds is just a ticket that
close the gasm in the technology
adoption curve and when you think about
this and you think about you know all
the different business schools harvard
business school Stafford so many people
are talking about what is digital going
to mean today right and there's so many
different business models on demand
inventory we live in a slow growth
economy today right how do you create
value if you're a CFO in a slow growth
economy you've got to free up capital is
one of the simplest ways to do it
there's so many companies with billions
of dollars of slow-moving inventory
inventory that's been sitting around for
a decade and a lot of its plastic parts
and plastic polymer parts degrade over
time they densify they get brittle they
hydrolyze they fade you actually want a
fresh park let alone a a part that's on
your books for all that time period and
so on demand inventory is a new business
model could you have a warehouse in the
cloud where you just pull it down make
parts as you need them where you're on
an oil rig somewhere or maybe you're in
a remote village and your and your water
irrigation systems gone down you need
parts you think about all the different
new business models that are going to
change Jeff ml CEO of GE gave a really
great graduation speech at NYU this past
spring and he talked about the end of
globalization that he believes that all
the trade barriers that countries are
erecting are going to require them they
have a very different posture going
forward he says his us factories at GE
are going to be manufacturing for the US
market
and exports are going to go down and
that they need to be able to make
product in country or in region to be
competitive local for local production
and one of the key fundamental tenets of
that business model is having a digital
factory a platform that could make
anything a flexible factory and again
the digital revolution is going to
really enable these entire new business
models and so but the key is what's
blocking that is they haven't been
economically fabricated and they're not
real parts so we believe we can we can
be the trigger to open up these entire
new business models and we're very
excited about that so a future
fabricated with light that chisel think
about light as a chisel is really what
drives us and the last thought I'll
leave you with is okay what's the big
deal it has light and this sounds risky
has life been used anywhere else to
drive manufacturing and you know
especially here in Silicon Valley to
think about you know the semiconductor
industry is driven by patterned light in
photo lithography and that's using
pattern light in two dimensions to make
all the memory chips all the wafers all
the integrated circuits that we we come
to rely on it's all made with light but
we're using light in three dimensions
and the opportunities to drive a broader
manufacturing footprint and potentially
have a bigger impact than even the
semiconductor industry is something
we're very very excited about so we've
got an amazing company it's an honor as
a faculty member to serve and be part of
this team this is our board of directors
our boards as you know are
representative of their investors and
then you get a couple independent board
members our independent board members
include Alan Mulally he was a former CEO
Ford Motor Company another great book
read about Alan Mulally American icon
how he saved the for Motor Company and
he was also president of boeing
commercial air division really a big
proponent of digital manufacturing and
then Ellen Coleman just joined our board
she's a recently retired chairman CEO of
DuPont so emphasizing the material
science
if the app the app store for resin focus
of our company so a really great advice
for us going forward and that our
investors are some of the most iconic
investors in Silicon Valley right I love
as an entrepreneur coming from the east
coast I love being a Silicon Valley key
valley and all you folks here with
Stanford are really in a special
position I think being here in Silicon
Valley is what it must have felt like
being in Florence during the Renaissance
this is the place for doing
entrepreneurship and that's why we here
at carbon are in Silicon Valley our
investors include Sequoia Capital think
about cisco and apple and paypal and
yahoo and whatsapp right silverlake the
largest private equity technology firm
they broke all their rules to lead a
series b investment in a startup company
because they knew the impact that
digital manufacturing was going to have
and in Google Ventures when I walked on
the stage as of ted larry page and
sergey brin were in the audience we had
a booth we had our parts shortly
thereafter google ventures letter let
our series c and most recently we did a
series c extension led by our customers
and people that are really focused on
manufacturing and BMW GE nikon and jsr
we're very excited to have them on a
team and with that really thrilled to be
here and thank you for your attention be
happy to answer any questions
question yes here's Al Jarreau map
receipt address larger parts and second
question is the networking algorithm to
mention is that supervising yeah so the
question was what is our product roadmap
and in particular to ask about larger
parts and yeah absolutely you could see
the product roadmap be absolutely
focused on actually that window
technology that the the key to having a
window that was extensible to larger
areas was something we actually had a
technologically tick off on series b
funding and so our window now is
scalable to large areas and our product
roadmap reflects that in your second
question supervised or unsupervised
algorithms you're now networking or what
putting good no I don't know what that
means actually yeah also the machine
learning aspects it I'm a chemist I
appreciate that being comfortable with
what you don't know i'm sharing
vulnerable trusts here we're a little
bit more like a mechanical turk right
now but you know our is our sensors get
it it's with more humans playing
intervening on this but the opportunity
for doing doing analysis is is there
great question yes you see plastics and
polymers replacing metals as you're
going forwards did you see the movie the
graduate you're a little young there was
a classic line in a graduate where they
said plastics plastics plastics right
that was in the 70s I thing right there
is a there was a star trek movie later
on where the one where they're trying to
rescue the whale and they needed a big
pool of water and Scotty you don't even
know Star Trek Scotty needed he was
looking for some transparent aluminum
and they had poly carbonate he says
you're still using polymers at joke
should resonate it's not so we'll
polymers take over metal so you in your
car that car is loaded with advanced
polymeric materials and composites and
polymers are more expensive than metal
and glass and so you ask why or polymers
making such an infiltration into
automotive well the reason is it can
simplify manufacturing steps because you
can make more complex things they can be
lighter weight they can be safer right
so there's a lot of reasons in a whole
host of applications why yes polymers is
a massive industry it's a 400 billion
dollar industry in the United States you
think of our you think about all the
wearables I'm pointing to a metal watch
but you think about all the wearables
people have and all your all your
devices your your laptops there's so
many places where advanced materials
especially in aerospace automotive
consumer electronics those are met those
are all polymeric materials so yes it's
a huge market and but it's been held
back by now having real materials made
economically why I felt like I really
dated myself there yes so some people
have expressed like concern about like
enjoy the video using clip so how you
been able happy some of these people are
there's associatively yeah Terry walrus
that's good the question was Terry
wooler had a ruler's report and i think
it was we had an article by Forbes or
fortune and and you know you always
what's really great is you always have
what's really you know when you put
yourself out there a lot of people will
comment on what you're doing and Terry
is grounded in the current industry and
he was asking about our UV stability in
particular and if you're knowledgeable
and materials polymeric materials what
you'll quickly not acknowledge is that
some of the most UV unstable materials
one of the most UV on stable materials
is as natural rubber which makes up all
the car tires that are baking in the Sun
right and a lot of those materials are
stabilized by things like carbon black
and other things that allow a nap a
material to have great material
properties be UV stable and so using a
similar approach we have very stable
systems and but that's not been the
history if you use light to set the
shape and to set the properties you're
going to be you're going to be hard
pressed to have a UV stable system but
using our approach with light to set the
shape and chemistry set the properties
our customers have already proven that
we have stable systems it was a
long-winded answer readers to you need
to to get into a lot of these
applications and so we in various not
only us but our customers you know it's
really interesting to from an
entrepreneurship point of view you could
give a customer set of data and they're
like yeah that's great we're going to do
it ourselves and a replicate what it is
you're doing is so that even that UV
data that showed you on the screen was
not our data was our customers data yes
changing the mindset of engineers and
the industry from gfs tube devices yeah
so it's coming to places like this so
the question was how do we train a new
generation of engineers to have the
think about design freedoms or additive
manufacturing versus traditional
manufacturing and it's I think I think
the key place is to start with where a
lot of new engineers are emerging put
these new tools at that's why we're
really focused on getting some printers
into the university setting and but you
know we when we look at some of our big
customers what's interesting is they
have prototyping shops where they're
already it's like it's like preaching to
the choir they already know but the
engineers at these companies don't buy
in in fact hate 3d printing I can't tell
you I've had so many CTOs and CEOs of
some of the biggest companies in China
and the United States come and visit
carbon and some of them come reluctantly
we had a common
fester and one story and a common
investor said you gotta go see carbon
and go see these parts and he said I
hate 3d printing it's never going to
amount to anything in fact I'll change
my name if it ever amounted to anything
and you may new who I'm talking about
now notorious for saying that but we had
there you know those folks hold on to
these parts and say that we've changed
their worldview so it's a combination of
how do we penetrate an existing market
place and major industrials but also
starting with universities is a little
bit of our tactic last question yeah um
how do you think so if 3d printing is
going to become the huge thing that
everybody thinks it's going to come how
do you think carbon is going to end all
the change in two people having a 3d
printer in their home yeah so what's
interesting is the consumer marketplace
emerged the makerspace the maker
community emerged very quickly and with
and I think there's a lot of people that
are probably frustrated by the quality
of what's being of what they're making
and and but there are some great
examples where it is working but I you
know I think that the content is quite
limited there what enters other people
competing in that marketplace and it's
one of the most innovative marketplaces
for ideas and it's one that we want to
foster that's why we put printers and
service bureaus we actually had a bunch
of skateboard experts down into San
Diego LA area make skateboard wheels and
new trucks and the whole goal was to
beat the crap out of our parts and show
that it you know and it they were
skateboarding for like an hour and
nothing and a video terminated so
they're really happy camper so we're
feeding that community but we're trying
to do something that no one's doing
that's do a 3d manufacturing and that is
really the opportunity to cross the
chasm for economic buyers but with some
of our partners there's a
consumer-facing when we start coming out
with products that you all will be using
you'll see carbon and how we brand
carbon with some of these new products
is something that will be exploring here
in a very near future that we're excited
about
I'm sure you'll agree this is incredibly
fascinating please join me and thank you